J’en rêve… Une vraie poignée de main, bien ferme.
Ce geste remonte au Ve siècle avant JC.
A l'époque, les agressions à l’arme blanche
étaient très fréquentes.
Pour rassurer un interlocuteur,
on avait donc pris l’habitude de tendre la main
pour lui montrer qu’elle était vide.
Petit à petit, les mains ont fini
par se toucher pour matérialiser le lien.
Sur certains bas-relief grecs,
ici, il s’agit d’une stèle tombale,
on voit déjà des hommes se serrer la main.
Par ailleurs, on sait qu’au Moyen Âge,
les chevaliers utilisaient entre eux ce signe
pour montrer qu’ils n’avaient pas
de mauvaises intentions.
Ils tendaient la main droite, parce qu’à l’époque,
on tenait l’épée de la main droite.
Cette même main droite que l’on se serait encore,
il y a quelques semaines.
Mon petit doigt me dit
que ce n’est pas près de recommencer.
En attendant, peut-être que l’on peut
pour se saluer : tirer la langue
comme le font les moines tibétains.
Avec un masque, pas sûr que ça serve à grand chose.
Surtout ne pas se toucher le bout du nez,
comme le célèbre « hongi » mâori.
Reste le signe de tête.
C’est ce que font les chinois dans la vie courante.
Et ça pourrait bien devenir contagieux…
comme cette « capsule de déconfiné ».
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo et le chant de l’oiseau,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir les vidéos
des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
J’en publie une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour être sûr de n’en louper aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
A demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes toujours confinés mais on reste en lien.
Pas vrai l’oiseau ?